la save us on the fire laughs it was fun
to fire mercy on this me like hundred I
said I'll make home
greetings a piece I made of your host
you're watching the Dean show today we
are going to be interviewing Imam
Mustafa Zaid was the author of the first
book in the English language that
addresses all the lies a legate false
allegations of the last and final
messenger sent them a kind of problem
I'm a peace be upon him you have to
understand that there has always been
resistance to the truth when Jesus came
peace be upon him it wasn't always sugar
and roses at his arrival you had people
who were resisting him they even tried
to kill him Moses at the same time when
he came with the truth you had people
were throwing a party they tell him look
you can't be doing that
and there was resistance the last and
final messenger sent a man kind of
problem having peace be upon him who
came with the same message as Jesus
Moses Abraham all the messages got that
message was to worship the One God and
not what he created and a lot of times
is bad for business
people worshipping statues monkeys idols
men women all these other things and now
people going to lose their position
politics all these things play a role so
they start to do childish things they
start to slander the messengers of God
and today the last and final messenger
said to mankind is a problem hard please
be a problem and there's a lot of lies
against him so we hope that you have an
open heart and open mind this is such an
important topic show that we're going to
be addressing here on the Deen show and
we come back we're going to clear the
fog clear the junk so you can have the
truth delivered to you in a clear
precise manner we'll be right back
so I'll make one piece and I'm are you
how are you good good thing come to LA
thank you for being with us on the show
there :
you have your own section at the Dean
show calm people go there to read a
little bit about you now it's
interesting now that you spend a lot of
time on this book two years two years
tell us all about the book what made you
decide to write this book
well actually I give a class for so many
years to people who accepted Islam and I
teach them the Dean and the manners of
the Prophet and so on and so forth and
about two years ago a very decent Muslim
woman accepted Islam and she came to me
and said this is what is being pushed to
people and people people are told this
is the Prophet that now is your prophet
this is the religion they now accepted
and it was a book called the truth about
Muhammad written by Robert Spencer I do
not know who he is he's the one who
founded jihad watched he is the
co-founder of stop the Islamization of
America that is leading the opposition
again it's building the mosque near
Ground Zero
they put banners on buses in New York
City that says you know what if you want
to convert away from Islam or leave
Islam or there's a fatwa against you
that you want to run away we'll help you
get away from Islam in the business of
bashing Islam and I looked at the book
and you know you read two pages and you
cannot even continue the most abhorrent
misinformation lies about problem Hamid
and Islam in an unbelievable way and the
problem is to the average American who
does not know and it's our fault that
the average American does not know you
would think that this is must be true
about the Prophet I counted a hundred
and fifty five
about promises and allegations that you
refute in your book yes once that he can
imagine one that he cannot imagine with
all kind of logical conclusions the most
unreliable resources and outright
fabrications on lies and I took it upon
myself I said allah subhanaw taala i
would ask me with whatever little
knowledge that I have had I learned
about this and did not stand up for from
homicide Asylum when I started writing
it the level of crazy Islamophobia and
hatred against Muslim was not even close
to what is it right now but it was the
planning of a loss of Hannah Tyler that
the book is just released when it's
needed
nowadays and what I did is that I went I
took every paragraph every page page by
page for a grab by paragraph and I
refuted him with the blessing of Allah
subhanAllah with quote and certain logic
history even from the Old Testament and
the New Testament as well
now tell us I mean a Muslim is one who
wants to to live in peace he wants to
live in peace with himself and he gets
that peace by submitting to the one guy
the one who Jesus submitted to who Moses
submitted to all the messengers of God
they were Muslims because they did Islam
and Islam is to acquire peace by
submitting your will to the owner if
he's the one God and we don't want to
blow nobody up we we don't want to
oppress nobody we want justice and mercy
for all and that's why we're doing this
program to clear the confusion to get
the drunk out of junk out of the trunk
and that's why we have people such as
yourself that are credible people that
can help educate the masses and that's
why we're doing this so why do you think
it is I had mentioned something in the
Bing in another show that when all the
messengers came they had resistance yes
why do you think someone would go ahead
and write a book and lie actually
multiple books and multiple people I
chose that author because he's one of
the leading bachelors of Islam is
businesses bashing Islam people need to
understand it's not an ideology as an
opposition of another ideology or
difference of opinions it's a very
profitable business actually it's the
most profitable business nowadays
bashing Islam bashing it's like making
money off hadn't people the American
people believed
that bastion of Islam after September 11
that Islam is a religion of violence and
terrorism and oppression of women and
minorities they would have not allowed
or agreed that we go to a country that
is Iraq that never done anything to us
pillage the US Treasury for over three
trillion dollars today killing hundreds
of thousands of innocent civilians in a
country that had done nothing to us
killing even American kids like almost
5000 of them on hundreds of thousand of
mental diseases and amputations and and
injuries and so on and so forth if it
wasn't for Islamophobia that would have
not happened these three trillion
dollars would have not happened it's a
very profitable business and the thing
that I want to bring to our viewers is
that these kind of books the truth about
Mohammed and maybe the other books are
not out there to bother you or just to
you know take you and convert you from
Islam they're out there to wash the
average American we're not the majority
in this country this is to wash the mind
of the average American so when the time
is needed they would be out there to
execute us hurt us or you know do
whatever they want to another Muslim
country without anybody saying anything
because guess what in their mind in the
wrong perception Islam is violence and
terrorism and such and such and such and
we would be asked by allah subhanaw
taala if we allow that to be mentioned
about our name and the the Prophet peace
be upon it most of the allegations these
books are not just phone they're the
opposite total opposite of the truth I
was interviewed by CNN radio the other
day yeah and two things that I said the
first thing is that I'll give an analogy
to the allegations against Prophet
Mohammed I said I'm an Islam as someone
described in Shaquille O'Neal to you as
a short white really poor guy Shaquille
O'Neal that's the famous best as a short
white really poor guy but not just wrong
totally the opposite and this is what
they do in these books absolutely and
the other thing that was so shocking to
me is that the talk show lewis was very
educated very progressive very invited
person and he allowed me to speak my
mind and i thank him for that he had to
ask me the first question that he
thought that on everyone's mind
including his and he needed to hear the
answer from a muslim scholar what is the
present question out there with
non-muslims here's the question
if you are Muslim and you meet a
Christian or a Jew isn't mandated really
by Islam that you have to convert him
and if they don't convert you have to go
ahead and kill him he asked you that he
asked me that
yeah and it's a sincere question he
really wanted to know that that's the
level of Islamophobia and hatred and
misinformation and fabrications about
Islam that is out there and as a Muslim
scar I didn't know what to do laugh or
cry because it's so absurd and so
couldn't be further from the truth but
this is a reality that we're facing
channel also Hannah had blessed me to
produce the book 100 so how did you
answer this
I answered could it be further from the
truth the cardinal rule in Islam is no
compulsion in religion and even if let's
say through violence you force someone
to accept Islam his belief is not
accepted by God because he really does
not believe and you would carry the sin
of prison someone's right and promise I
sell them and the greatest prophets of
Islam never done that it's couldn't be
further from the truth
but that's what the average American
brother and sister is learning about
Islam from these people tell us now many
people are still on the minds of many
and they want to revisit 9/11 so what we
have to say about that does Islam have
anything to do with 9/11
let's hear prophet of islam talking
about terrorism maharaj allah almighty
Yod removal rahul fatiha well I at the
hash I mean well I am for Olivia Donato
fellows Thurman who Fischer in what is a
mini fisheye what does that mean whoever
comes out to my nation any people any
group of people it's the good in the bed
without avoiding the believers and not
hurting the good people without keeping
a pledge that he gave to people and
Muslim automatically when you move to a
new society you have and stayed there
for three days
you have given these people a romantic
pledge of peace and security because
they allowed you to live amongst
themselves if you do that you have
absolutely nothing to do with problem
homicides in them and he has absolutely
nothing to do with you he's in paradise
you and Hellfire as simple as that the
highest punishment and the biggest
punishment for any crime in Islam which
is what is called haba haba that's in
the Sharia law that they scare people
with is indiscriminate killing of
innocent people there's nothing more
punishable
in Islam its execution in public in a
way that makes an example of the
assailant
now whether there were 19 criminals 190
criminals that killed indiscriminately
innocent people including many hundreds
of Muslims they're just criminals
they're not Muslims they're not Jews
they're not Christians they're just
criminals and the biggest most
punishable law out there to punish these
people and bring them to justice is
Islamic law had they been caught
according to the law of the state of New
York they're I've got life in prison
free health care and you know maybe
kosher food and nutritional food in
Islam as I said they would have been
executed in public so crimes are
committed left and right in the name of
other religion McVeigh is you know makes
Christianity as responsible for his
action as these people may make Islam
responsible for the crime Islam
Christianity and all religions and all
people are not responsible them their
own biological brothers and sisters are
not responsible for the crime in any law
in the land in any country in the world
so how come 1.6 billion people are
already criminals and Muslim Americans
would have to be punished for criminals
that God only knows who financed him and
who made it that easy for them to commit
such a horrible crime yes indeed it was
horrible and Islam has nothing to do
with it we'll be right back with more
here on the Dean show
there always be someone that'll be there
to say something negative but at the
same time there'll be someone there to
say something positive hold on to the
rope over everything in this universe
can you lie I need a lot of it the Quran
says don't kill women don't kill
children don't kill the old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told the Prophet Allah
never ever stopped a war against back
here on the Deen show with Imam mr. faz
aid who is the author of the lies about
Muhammad Muhammad we don't worship
Muhammad he is the last and final
messenger sent to mankind he was a
messenger just like Jesus Moses Abraham
Noah they all call people to do God's
will yes just like in the Lord's Prayer
hallowed be thy name thy will be done
this is Islam submit to God not to your
desires not to a man not to one but to
create a man and woman so now the last a
final messenger problem Hamid peace be
upon him who sent as a mercy to the
world there's a lot of allegations and
lies childish things that people are do
we need to be living in peace
cooperating to do good but obviously you
have people who are against doing good
and making mischief in the land so there
are a lot of allegations 155 of them
that you covered in this book and give
up some some more of these allegations
and how you refute it actually but the
real thing that incensed me is that it's
not anymore about the controversial
issues yeah it's about making people
hate Islam for obvious reasons that we
talked about so creating something that
is really opponent and people hate and
try to find something Islam that you can
fabricate and mutilate in a way that
make believe that actually Islam is this
thing for example I'll give an example
say there's ever been - Josh was the
cousin of the Prophet he's seen her a
million times and because there are no
classes of Islam his former servant is a
dome the ha'la'tha
from homicide and persuading her to
marry him so she married him but she
kept talking down to him she's from a
noble family she's the cousin of the
Prophet and he was a former slave or
former servant so what happened is that
he kept coming to promise I said I want
to divorce her promises Salomon the
Koran and certain or m/c Caracas
it's a killer hold on to your wife if
you're lost parent Allah the worst is
bad do not divorce her tell it escalated
then the worst had to happen they got
divorced and after three months she's
the cousin of the Prophet he's the one
who persuaded her for the marriage so
against the customary of having any of
the Companions marry her to honor her
promises Ellen went ahead and married
her here's what mr. Spencer says problem
homicide seldom went to the house of
Zaid even Harry thought when he was not
there and of course you know what I know
as a Muslim that's the last thing
problem mama so Selim would do entering
a house of a man while the man is not
there and he seems ni but the judge for
the first time yeah she's not his cousin
anymore he never seen her
he's not even the one who did the
marriage and she excited his admiration
so we decided to divorce her from his
son as a dude my heart and that was his
son and marry her for him own self
that's the level and how new things get
there it's just clear lies lies and
omission of the fact you know you go to
the incident of the famous one oh my
Melek at a Manickam meaning that a
Muslim man is allowed to marry up to
four women with rules that he has to be
fair it does not like it should as for a
divorce so adultery does not happen and
so and this is very missed by many
Muslim scholars and in America the
second wife is a human being too
she would walk around as a wife and her
children are legitimate she's not a
mistress she's not a girlfriend if it
has to happen and it's happening left
and white then she's a wife and the
first wife does not like it as a major
change in marriage like you know
whatever that happens
he's a miser who loses his job or is it
start drinking or violent whatever that
happens in any marriage these massive
changes she can ask for a divorce but
then in conditions of for at the time of
promise I said Ossipon I allowed him to
actually have sexual relationships with
more than four wives all my America
America must the story he calls him six
slaves in his birth in his book what's
the story
Muslims go Ribeiro in a harsh desert
they went now the wife and children left
over what to do with them the trick that
they play on you you know as if it were
in the 21st century in midtown Chicago
or midtown
is that you know what what they do the
Muslim soldiers take him back home as
six slaves but you're talking about the
middle of the seventh century in a hard
desert okay they would leave him what
would happen to them Wolf's would eat
him alive they're going to be enslaved
they're gonna be tortured they're gonna
be prostituted they're gonna be killed
what would happen next you gonna bring
him to the Muslim society and leave him
without a sponsor what would happen you
forced him into stealing and cheating
and prostitution to survive how are they
gonna survive that the most civil way is
to find a faster for them a sponsor for
them how would that work a Muslim man
who has the ability of a financial
ability to take him exactly as wives but
without giving him the title of voice
why for inheritance right because when
your wife you have certain inheritance
rights and lineage rights and she would
be treated exactly like a wife she is in
the same living standard and he would be
responsible for her it would be her own
reputation her children are legitimate
and there are his as soon as she gives
birth to a child then that child carries
the name of the father and she's free to
stay with him or to start his own life
without forcing her to become a Muslim
or anything like that problem mama says
LM in the middle of the seventh century
said whoever had such a woman taught her
manners educated her taught her how to
read or write treated her well and then
set her free and married her then he
would get double the reward from Allah
so Hanif
so that woman that you're talking about
now that the man educated her to kill
her their care for her now she is a wife
if he has you know it has only one wife
or the first time to get married yeah a
genius solution a merciful solution and
it's not like you know you stayed with
this man one day and the other man one
day she's like a wife it's his
reputation her children are named after
him and they couldn't be any better
solution at the time than this this is
just another detail of the proofs
improves I mean if you really look at
this it's just that because obviously if
you go deep into the Quran you see this
memorized by millions there's no other
book like you the scientific facts tells
you what the purpose of life is where
you go me to everything is there no book
like it challenge from the Creator if
you feel it's from other than the
Creator find one contradiction on a
little planet but now you
see like in times of war you know men
see this is an opportunity to rape to
pillage you know to hurt innocent women
but you're talking about something that
now there's a solution there's a system
even at least mercy was lamb he closed
them six slaves and actually this is the
best thing that ever happened to this
woman and most of them accepted Islam
and actually the defeat of their spouses
before was the best thing that had ever
happened to them by their admission I
want to move 500 years forward in the
future with the advancement and and the
better life and now imagine 500 years
from now how technologically advanced
and savvy and civilized we would be what
are the Crusades Crusades came to
Jerusalem on their way to Jerusalem any
Jewish person the child man woman old
young they killed them all without mercy
without cause indiscriminate ricochets
now course a yellow yeah yes yes but we
know that this has not ndu the teachings
of Jesus peace be upon him here they
hijacked Christianity yeah and then when
they went on Jerusalem the first thing
is the appetizer gathered every Jew in
the city put them all in one synagogue
and burn the synagogue with the innocent
worshippers a life inside
never mind six slaves and then within
six days they killed 70,000 living Souls
every Muslim human being in the city of
Jerusalem infant child recently born old
man old woman without mercy a matter of
fact in the Arabic language there's a
phrase called Adam Miller rucap blood
was to the need level that phrase was
coined that week and Jerusalem Robert
Spencer that I refuted his claims here
claims that the Crusaders
would just claim him back their
properties that the Muslims took from
them as if the Middle East was a Roman
property as if someone like me is
actually blond but does not know what
amazing and these are the comparisons
that they give you that Muslims took
these ladies as sexualize imagine the
decency and the treatment and the honor
that they give to these people and the
opportunity without and I want to add
this forcing them to convert this left
hold that point we're going to
ask you a question for you to tell us in
history where anything was done if
Muslims did these kind of barbaric
things in history or the examples of
mercy when Muslims had the upper hand
we want to pick your brain to give us
some examples of this when we come back
here on the detail when outside
everything looks good you see the
hundred thousand dollar cars you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is a life this is this is like no
paradise right here are to someone's
heart to change their heart your job is
to topi what the truth is and the idea
of it is while we're sitting here while
I'm sitting here constantly paying for
the disease the cure was free
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking about the lies about the last
and final messenger sentiment kind of
problem Hamid peace be upon him and I
wanted to have you please tell us was
there anything you mentioned the
Crusades and you also mention that this
was a hijacking of the true teachings of
Jesus yes we loved very much
absolutely we agree that he was one of
the mightiest messengers of God and tell
us is there anything in history that
someone that he points out that the
Muslims they did these kind of things
you look at actually one of the most
well known Orientalist thomas carlyle
wait wait before you go on I just want
to take it back not that the Muslims did
I'm timing when Islam because Muslims
are human beings they make mistakes but
when Islam was implemented properly yes
that I wanted to rephrase he made a very
nice observation actually he said if
Islam was intolerant to minorities and
other religions and Judaism excuse me in
Christianity how is it that Eastern
Churches that were separated from the
rest of the prison them at the time they
were considered heretics by room by the
Vatican by the Catholic Church and they
would not support them by any stretch of
the imagination how come these churches
are still standing nowadays how come
there's millions of Arab Christians and
you know Asian and Christians living in
Muslim countries today by the millions
who supported them other than that
tolerance of the general of leniency of
mercy of the ruling system of Islam
throughout all these centuries for
example when Ferdinand and Isabelle came
to and Dallas where the Muslims were
there you convert or we kill you as
simple as that the eradicated Judaism
and Islam from that part of the world
there are no Muslims there very minor a
big minority there when louisa xiv
mandated that you know what if you're
not Catholic we're going to kill you so
all the Protestant
were prosecuted and made it a crime to
be a Protestant in a matter of fact you
get testimonies from Christians in
Eastern Europe thanking that for the
rule of Muslims when the Ottoman Empire
came and occupied because now they can
have tolerance and religious freedom
because the Muslims would not you know
force you to convert to their religion
would take the do taxes as much as the
Muslim it has to pay their his due taxes
and you have religious freedom I have in
the book the lies about Mohammed the
patriarch of an taki in Turkey thanking
God for the Turks meaning the Muslims
for their lives because now they can
breathe some religious freedom from the
oppression of other Christian worlds
that rule them before this is known in
history now absolutely it cover others
in your banner documented it here a few
more points to come to the end you
mentioned the tax they say look it's
long calms it belittles you it
subjugates you puts the design you were
to say first of all it's a form of tax
like a Muslim paste that so Muslim is
obligated to pay two and a half percent
to charity tax so it's not that you want
your non-muslim you don't you pay taxes
and Muslims lip tax-free everyone pays
tax and the matter-of-fact non-muslims
paid less tax than the Muslims why the
Torah half percent is form whatever
unspent assets that I have I could be a
billionaire and my unspent assets could
be limitless and so is that one I have
percent the jizya for the non Muslim is
one dinar which is equivalent to about a
hundred dollars per year parody able to
fight in the family the rabbi does not
pay the priest does not pay the little
kid does not pay the woman that children
do not pay only the man was able to
carry a sword and it's $100 per year
you're paying like what 30 40 percent of
your wealth right now what are you
complaining about exactly so you know
it's paying their due taxes without any
subjugating you live the same exact way
an islamic law you steal from a
non-muslim you steal from a Muslim
whatever it is in the law is totally
blind to that so the jizya tax is
actually one of the brightest moments of
the talents of islamic law when it's
dealing with minorities or non-muslims
totally opposite what you get what you
hear yes opposite to the truth that's
the norm when it comes to people badges
land we really wouldn't want to thank
those sincere humble
been minded sincere people who want to
know the truth who aren't blinded by
this that now they're really wanting to
hear what we have to say not letting CNN
Fox News or Johnny Spence whether is the
Robert Spencer and actually I want to
you know point to something very
important good parents Muslim mothers
and fathers come to me and say you know
my son came back from school and he
denounced Islam and the reason is here
at one of these absurd allegations that
he can answer with one sentence as
simple as one a or one hundred Mama's I
said lamb but he did not know it keeps
lurking in their mind and they have no
answer all of a sudden they're in
college or have you know economic
freedom I don't wanna be a Muslim
anymore and if that is said what's even
worse is that sometimes the parents
themselves good worship and pray Muslims
do not know the answers and they're
simple so I beg the viewers pick up a
copy learn it for yourself give it as a
gift three children your children when
they read it they would love it because
whether they tell you or not they're
bombarded in public schools and colleges
with these absurd allegations and I
cannot blame the average American
because we did not tell the average
American otherwise yeah a few more
points from our points we're almost
coming to an end it's signaling that
were almost out of time another thing
that they some of the opponents of Islam
don't mention that now we deceive that
we lie that you know you know this is
just that that Mickey Mouse Islam that
we're trying to you know because we're
under the heat and the pressure and now
it's okay Islam lets you lie to deceive
the people what do you guys say about
that have you heard they come yes they
come to something called the clear yes
the clear
that's what nothing to do with this land
nothing to do with Islam it's some there
were some factions of Islam that totally
deviated from the message even their
ideology some time came in to blasphemy
and cough and they were outlawed by
Muslims so they came up with this thing
very small minority and historically
insignificant that they started with
this thing you know what do not show
your ideology of blasphemy to the
average Muslim so you are not you know
prosecuted and you know chased out of
the city
so the bachelors of Islam and including
mr. Robert Spencer even in his website
makes that the clayey which is a
criminal behavior
deceptive behavior as if it is the
normal behavior of the 1.6 billion
Muslims why so when people look at
Muslims and nowadays and say they're
innocent they're good they're my doctors
they're my good friends they're very
good people
he hasn't executed no it's mandated and
their religion to deceive you are we
receiving the American public by having
25% of the doctors that heal Americans
being Muslims even though we're not 5%
of the population and if we deceive for
the purpose of what what happens ylim is
done with that deception show me we have
49 years of history there was always the
most truthful the most honest when Islam
was applicable and that the higher thing
is such a small minority in some of the
factions of the Shia Muslims not even
Shiite Muslims themselves and it's a
man-made thing and it's not in the
correct hadith from Hamas I am on the
Quran how dare you say that this is a
slap it's not in the quotation of the
Prophet of Islam or the Koran itself
blatant lie absolutely and how do you
see most of these and we're coming to an
end a closed most of the things that he
this Mickey Mouse offense or whatever
his name is I'm sorry Robert Smith
Johnny Spencer whatever his name is tell
us how does he or anyone else what do
they usually do did a misquote did a
cut-and-paste or would you say go to the
most unreliable resources like some
people that have nothing to do the
Prophet or Islam even people that are
being executed for blasphemy and quote
him his best source is openness half who
is someone who whatever story that he
heard about prophet Moses telling me put
down out of good intentions but it's
like someone who goes to Houston and get
the tabloids and then your post and then
the New York Times and The Washington
Post and putting together some are very
truthful and some are outright lies the
scholars that came after him and Bukhari
and Muslim told us exactly which one is
the true quotation and which one is not
he only takes the one The Satanic Verses
once the crazy ones and say that oh this
is Islam does not code the six major
references of Islam mutilate versus take
verses out of context give me an example
the torture that the early Muslims
received on the hands of the pagans
of course never mentioned an entire book
200 pages about promise I seldom how
they were tortured persecuted you know
starved and killed not mentioned that so
when the Muslims fight it as if the
Muslims we're you know aggressors and so
on and so forth you know and I can go
for days about it's really horrible so
much to cover and you cover all that 155
false allegations you cover in your book
yeah the lies about Mohammed yes get the
book get the book
thank you very much resemble of it is
that God Almighty Allah reward you all
and thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Deen show and thank you
for being sincere open mind humble heart
you want to know the truth and you came
to the Muslims to learn the truth but
you know what it's really important that
you understand this first major
foundation bedrock of Islam because all
these other things you know they've been
there and they've been refuted and these
are childish things that people do who
aren't trying to really bring people
together who aren't really striving for
peace but we want peace and how do you
get peace you submit to the owner of
peace the one God and that's what Islam
is all about
it's submitting to the create or
worshipping the one God the same God of
Jesus Abraham Moses and all the
messengers of God they call people to
the same way of life they call people to
acquire peace by submitting to the owner
of peace the one God not for and one
three one six and one not a man or a
woman but the creator of man if you can
understand this this is the main message
of Islam to worship the creator and not
his creation and to do righteous good
deeds to do good actions to develop
yourself to be the best human being this
is what Islam is calling the human being
to do and if you can dig this you can
dig a stop keep coming back here to the
Deen show we'll see you next time peace
to you
in the name of Allah the most gracious
the most merciful
I seek reputable
the Lord of mankind the king of mankind
the god of mankind from the evil of the
Whisperer who whispers evil in the
hearts of man who withdraws from his
Whisperer finding one's heart after one
remembers of love
who is within the hearts of mankind of
jinn and men I see beautiful oh I see